Thomas Alva Edison was born in 1847 in Milan, Ohio, U.S.A.
His father was of Dutch blood and his mother of Scotch.
He liked to ask questions about everything he encountered.
When Edison was in his childhood, he saw a man who was making a boat in the forest.
How can the boat float on the water, sir?
What? Why do you want to know that?
I am just wondering.
You don't need to know that. Go away!
He saw a beehive when he was still thinking about the boat in the forest.
Huh? What's that? What's in there?
He touched the beehive lightly, wondering at its shape.
Ah!
A hive of bees rushed at him suddenly.
One day, his mother called him for dinner, but he didn't answer.
Where are you, Alva? It's time for dinner!
Maybe he is at the barn.
He spends most of his time staying there these days.
They went to the barn together.
Alva! Alva! Are you there?
Shh! Please be quiet! You shouldn't make any noise, dad!
What are you doing here?
I'm brooding eggs to make them hatch.
His mother set her mind at ease and admonished him kindly.
They won't become chicks with that.
Get up and come for dinner.
But, dad told me that if I keep them warm, they will be hatched.
That doesn't mean that you can sit on them, Alva!
Several years later, Alva entered elementary school and his parents worried about him.
Because, he still had a barrage of questions about everything.
One day, he was in a math class.
One plus one is two.
Teacher, can you explain to me why?
You can just count them. Those are two!
Then, why can't it be three?
What? It's a rule. Just memorize it.